yeah you're making me realize that um
it's it's a good scientific question
whether lying is an effective
mechanism for integrating yourself and
succeeding in a social network in a
social
in a world that is social i tend to
believe
that honesty and love are evolutionary
advantages
in us in a in an environment
where there's a network of intelligent
agents but it's also very possible that
dishonesty
and manipulation and
uh even you know violence all those
kinds of things might be more beneficial
that's the old open question about good
versus evil but i tend to
there's some i mean i don't know if it's
a hopeful maybe i'm delusional
but it feels like karma is a thing
which is like if
long term the agents they're just kind
to others sometimes for no reason
will do better in a society that's not
highly constrained on resources it's
like people start getting weird and evil
towards each other and bad
when the resources are very low relative
to the needs of the
the populace especially at the basic
level like
survival shelter uh food all those kinds
of things
but um i i tend to believe that
uh once you have those things
established then
well not to believe i i guess i hope
that ai systems would be honest
but it's fun it's scary to think about
the touring test you know ai systems
that will
eventually pass the touring test will be
ones that are exceptionally good at
lying
that's a terrifying concept yeah
i mean i i don't know first of all so
from uh from somebody who studied
language and obviously
are not just the world expert in ai but
somebody who dreams about
the future of the field do you hope do
you think
there'll be human level or superhuman
level intelligences in the future
that uh we eventually built
well definitely hope that we can we can
get there
um one i think um important perspective
is that we are building ai to help
us uh that it is a it is tool like cars
or or language or
communication ai will help us be more
productive
and that is always a condition
it's not something that we build and let
run and it
becomes an entity of its own that
doesn't care about us
now of course really far in the future
maybe that might be possible but not in
the foreseeable future when we are
building it
and therefore we always in a position of
limiting what it can or cannot do uh
and the um
your point about lying is very
interesting
um even even in these highness societies
for instance
uh when a number of these hyenas band
together and they
they still they take a risk and steal
the kill they're always hyenas that hang
back
and don't participate in that risky
behavior but they
walk in later and and join the party
after the
after the kill and there are even some
that may
be ineffective and cause others to have
harm
uh so and like i said even bacteria
cheat and we see
in biology there's always some element
an opportunity if you have a i think
that is this because if you have a
society
in order for society to be effective you
have to have this cooperation and you
have to have trust uh
and and if you have enough of agents who
are able
to trust each other you can achieve a
lot more
but if you have trust you also have
opportunity for cheaters and liars
and i don't think that's ever going to
go away
there will be hopefully a minority so
that they don't get in the way
and we studied in these high-end
simulations like what the proportion
needs to be
before it it's no longer functional and
you can point out that you can tolerate
a few cheaters and a few liars and the
society can still function
and that's probably going to happen um
when when we build these systems that
autonomously learn
um the really successful ones are
honest because that's the best way of
getting things done
but there probably are also intelligent
agents that find that they can achieve
their goals by
by bending the rules of cheating
you